i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
me complace mucho estar en text medellín
la mayoría de las personas que me
conocen saben que me dedico a pensar la
ruralidad hace poco una amiga que quiero
muchísimo y que habita uno de los 125
municipios de nuestro departamento
antioquia me llamó un poco angustiada a
contarme una historia en su pueblo los
campesinos bajan a vender los alimentos
que producen a la plaza al parque
central
y ella me relató que ese día los
campesinos que habían bajado con los
alimentos para vender les tocó regresar
se sin haber vendido absolutamente nada
pensando la ruralidad
esta llamada me puso a reflexionar
bastante me desnudo porque no tuve
respuesta a la pregunta que ella me hizo
y era que podíamos hacer por aquellos
campesinos que no habían logrado vender
esos alimentos yo no supe cómo
responderle de manera concreta
contundente y empecé a reflexionar
después de colgar
y pensé aquellas lecturas que hacía de
las columnas de un gran pensador
colombiano en uno de los periódicos de
circulación diaria que tiene nuestro
país
william ospina en sus columnas empezaba
a relatar cómo las ciudades habían
perdido su esencia las ciudades
construidas en la cultura aquellas que
venían de nuestro mundo romano
y también de nuestro mundo indígena
donde concentraban en esencia el
pensamiento humano y como hoy la visión
de progreso de caminar con desarrollo
estaba llena de cemento y cada vez cada
vez más estrechos en unos lugares y es
que el dato no es menor en 1960 el mundo
estaba más o menos con una relación de
personas viviendo en lo urbano en un 47%
y en
en el 2020 en el de año que estamos hoy
la relación se invirtió ya somos casi
65% de las personas que vivimos en las
ciudades nuestro mundo tiene grandísimas
ciudades que superan los 20 millones de
personas ciudad de méxico sao paulo los
ángeles nueva york toque por ejemplo es
diez veces más grande que medellín y es
que es muy simple en la relación es como
tener una gran casa y todos los que
habitan esa casa querer vivir en el
cuarto útil
porque la concentración en las ciudades
es tan grande que la población la mayor
parte de la población
ese 63% 65% está viviendo en el 3 por
ciento del área entonces me puse a
reflexionar y a pensar bueno
que será entonces de nosotros y quién va
a producir esos alimentos era muy clara
la relación entre población y producción
porque para este año nosotros somos 7
mil 700 millones de personas para el
2050 seremos 9 mil 700 millones de
personas y entonces con tanta gente
habitando las ciudades quién va a
producir los alimentos quien se
encargará entonces de garantizarnos que
cada día tengamos algo que comer récord
de la llamada de mi amiga y dije hay que
volver a reinventar nuestra relación con
la ruralidad una ruralidad que nos está
ofreciendo sostén a estas grandes
ciudades y es claro que para eso no
necesitamos normas proyectos decretos
ordenamiento territorial lo que
necesitamos de verdad es
reinvertir nuestro pensamiento pensar
como nosotros con hábitos de consumo
logramos cambiar esas realidades y es
que cada vez consumimos más pero cada
vez también nos damos más y más
está
este trabajo por definir que realmente
es importante para nosotros como una
sociedad de cemento una sociedad urbana
en mi trabajo tengo bastantes quehaceres
bastantes cosas por hacer y casi no me
queda tiempo para cocinar y en uno de
esos afanes pues fui a un supermercado
pequeño y compre algo rápido para comer
para hacerme una pequeña sopa logré
conseguir una bolsa de legumbres que
estaba congelada y la llevé a mi casa
cuando llegué me di cuenta que esa
bolsita de legumbres estaba producida en
bélgica
y dije pero porque si nuestros
campesinos hoy
no tienen la oportunidad
de progresar y yo tomé una decisión que
no valoró esa ruralidad para acabar de
ajustar en esa ruralidad hoy
los que producen nuestro alimento
están en inseguridad alimentaria un dato
de la universidad de antioquia del año
pasado da cuenta de que el 75% de las
personas que habitan nuestra ruralidad
se encuentra en inseguridad alimentaria
pero como alguien que produce el
alimento está pasando hambre cómo es
posible que aquellas personas que
garantizan la comida de los millones de
habitantes de las ciudades tengan esas
dificultades y es que en nuestro
departamento antioquia que somos más o
menos 6 millones de personas un millón
400 mil personas viven en la ruralidad y
de esas el 75 por ciento están pasando
hambre como entonces nosotros podemos
reinventar reconstruir nuestra relación
con la ruralidad y no es que queramos
ser campesinos todos lo que queremos es
darle valor quisiera yo que todos
ustedes también cada vez que vayan a
mercar consigan una bolsa de frijol y
indaguen en esa etiqueta si el frijol
fue producido acá cerca
desafortunadamente incluso nuestra
bandeja paisa la que tanto orgullo nos
da casi el 70% de esa bandeja paisa
viene de otros lugares y también los dos
productos que más comemos frijol y arroz
vienen de otros lugares del mundo como
vietnam eeuu y cómo va a ser entonces
que perdamos esta posibilidad de valorar
lo local de comprarle a los campesinos
para entender que la transformación no
está en pensar que son unos pobres
campesinos lo que debemos es reconvertir
nuestro pensamiento tratar de hacer un
esfuerzo por comunicarnos con ellos a
través de nuestro progreso la forma de
adquirir nuestros hábitos de compra es
necesario que empecemos a comprar por lo
útil es necesario que todos esos
campesinos empiecen a entender
la ciudad los quiere y que ellos son el
sustento de nuestras ciudades y es que
otro dato que no es menor es que para el
2050 cuando seremos 9 mil 700 millones
de personas
vamos a necesitar mucha más agua y mucho
más alimento tendremos que producir 70
por ciento más de alimento de lo que
necesitamos ahora y quién lo hará si
todos queremos vivir en las ciudades
tenemos que empezar a partir de nuestro
corazón reconvertir esa relación qué tal
si unas vacaciones no nos dirigimos
solamente a aquellos sitios turísticos
sino que volvemos a llegar a aquellos
pueblitos a visitar necesitamos empezar
a relacionarnos mejor con la ruralidad
hoy es necesario retomar aquellas
reflexiones de nuestro gran pensador en
william ospina es necesario que
realicemos lo urbano
[Música]